y se cumplen cuatro meses desde que
comenzaron las protestas en Irán tras la
muerte de Max a Mini y Los jóvenes
siguen en las calles a pesar de la
represión del régimen al menos
quinientas son las personas que han
muerto según organizaciones de derechos
humanos y también centenares han sido
encarceladas desde el inicio cuatro
personas han sido ya ejecutadas en
relación con estas manifestaciones
analizamos toda la situación con Anita
nacida ella es politóloga y también
experta en Irán gracias a por estar con
nosotros en directo América de Francia
24 a agita vamos a hacer entonces un
balance de lo que ha ocurrido en estos
cuatro meses de las protestas tras la
muerte de Max examin
Hola buenos días Muchas gracias por
invitarme efectivamente el análisis
explicado anteriormente es muy acertado
y lo cierto Es que después de cuatro
meses la población iraní se encuentra
delante por una represión masiva y
brutal que lo que hace es
su función que es la de atemorizar a la
población y tiene miedo de salir y por
eso se ha pasado de protestas masivas a
luchas más pequeñas como de guerrilla
urbana solamente para desestabilizar un
poco la dinámica del régimen lo que sí
que es cierto es que la situación pase
lo que pase Y los iraníes en esto
tenemos mucha experiencia Es que la
realidad es que nunca va a poder volver
a ser lo mismo que hacer cuatro meses es
decir la situación en Irán puede ser que
se calme puede ser que la población
debido a la represión y que la vida la
realidad cotidiana Es que la gente tiene
que seguir viviendo a pesar de la
represión que puede ser que se acaben di
todas estas protestas pero que
seguramente como un fuego con brasas
quedarán y o semillas que algún día
brotarán así que los que como yo que
representamos una pequeña parte de los
iraníes fuera de Irán tenemos la
esperanza que algún día todas esas
semillas brotarán a fin de cuentas es
una lucha por los derechos básicos
universales son derechos las personas
están pidiendo nada más y nada menos que
algo que en occidente damos muy por
supuesto poder incluso ir en bicicleta
que aquí parece una tontería pero es que
ahora mismo allí las mujeres lo tienen
prohibido por ejemplo claro anahita
hacia dónde irán digamos todo todo este
movimiento estamos hablando Que
obviamente El futuro es incierto si bien
es cierto se pueden diluir Ahí va a
quedar como esa semilla de inconformismo
esa semilla de lucha sobre todo en la
generación más joven hablando de esa
generación quiero hilar
mi segunda pregunta y es eso y es cuánto
tenemos que esperar para que digamos
Esta generación joven crezca y pueda
llegar al poder no o si hay alguna forma
de cambio dentro de la misma revolución
la situación actual es que los que están
saliendo realmente a manifestarse Ahora
son hijos que ya han vivido solo bajo la
República islámica y sus padres o sus
abuelos no que sí que participaron
contra el sa o bien sufrieron después
las consecuencias de la República
islámica son los que no salen son los
que se quedan en sus casas por un
seguramente por una cantidad de
frustración acumulada durante todos
estos años y la desesperanza de que
todas las anteriores revueltas Siempre
han acabado en muy pocos cambios Lo
cierto es que el sistema ha surgido tras
la revolución islámica del 79 ha estado
es una estructura de órganos
institucionales muy bien hilvanados al
vértice del cual tenemos el líder
espiritual que es el que tiene la
decisión final en las decisiones más
importantes en el tema nuclear o las
fuerzas armadas o los medios de
comunicación por lo tanto hay que
trabajar para pedir y es lo que estaban
haciendo desde el comienzo al comienzo
pedían pequeños cambios del régimen pero
es que ahora piden un cambio de régimen
porque saben que con este régimen es
imposible un futuro como lo que tienen
en la mente o y lo que desean este
régimen no puede cambiar porque no sabe
que si la única arma que tiene ahora es
la represión Porque si cede un poco en
lo mínimo sabe que
la fisura cada vez será mayor y al final
acabará cayendo cómo le pasó al chat por
ejemplo
la comunidad internacional que papel han
jugado hasta el momento y en su opinión
o que deberían hacer no para ser masa
contundentes para tratar de apoyarnos
este este movimiento que pide libertad
que pide simplemente vivir una vida
normal claro la gente en Irán está
pidiendo conseguir un país democrático
laico y libre bajo un lema mujer vida
libertad la comunidad internacional la
sociedad civil se ha posicionado
claramente a favor de esta lucha porque
es una lucha repito de Derechos Humanos
básicos universales por lo tanto es muy
difícil no estar de acuerdo lo que sí
que es cierto es que a nivel
institucional internacionalmente No
hemos tenido un apoyo ha habido mucho
silencio internacional para nosotros fue
una Victoria la expulsión de Irán de la
comisión por el estatuto jurídico y
social de la mujer de Naciones Unidas ha
sido un gran éxito pero no es suficiente
hay que ir más allá hay que exigir el
cese inmediato de cualquier ejecución Y
de cualquier amenaza de pena de muerte
porque la pena de muerte al final es un
arma política que está utilizando el
régimen pedimos la liberación de estos
20.000 presos políticos que su única
causa por la cual han sido detenidos es
por haber pedido libertad Y seguramente
lo que necesitamos con más contundencia
es que no haya tanta hipocresía de los
gobiernos sabemos que hay muchos
intereses sabemos la importancia de Irán
como país geoestratégico pero realmente
un Irán democrático puede ser un gran
ejemplo para los países vecinos
Afganistán Irak y etcétera habladas de
algo muy importante que por supuesto
también acaparado muchos titulares en la
prensa internacional y son en las
lamentables ejecuciones que ha hecho el
régimen a jóvenes que han tenido
relación con estas protestas qué va a
pasar digamos en materia internacional
con lo que estaba ocurriendo Y si hay
posibilidad de alguna manera de parar
estas estas discusiones que siguen a los
sentenciados
a pesar que creamos que no sirve y
parezca simbólico la importancia de las
redes sociales en este movimiento Es
realmente crucial porque porque se puede
desde aquí podemos saber lo que está
pasando en el interior y los del
interior Pueden saber y pueden sentir
todo este apoyo internacional por lo
tanto la comunidad internacional tiene
que estar pendiente y tiene que condenar
la impunidad a la cual el régimen está
reprimiendo las revueltas y las
manifestaciones por el otro lado hay que
hacer una máxima presión para que el
gobierno no quede impune de estos ya
atentados y asesinatos de gente
realmente inocente porque el caso de los
cuatro ahorcados fue Solamente porque se
les acusó de mojar a ver que significa
guerra contra Dios o contra el islam que
es un término muy general sacado de la
manga desde los comienzos de la
república islámica Y es justamente para
poder detener y al final matar a
personas que sean disidentes con el
régimen la comunidad internacional tiene
que estar al lado de la población iraní
que es la única que tiene la solución a
su situación y es la única que puede
decidir Su futuro pero la comunidad
internacional tiene que posicionarse
claramente a favor de una lucha
democrática que evidentemente es muy
difícil y las revoluciones no se hacen
de un día para otro es un proceso muy
largo con sus altibajos pero la
comunidad internacional y los gobiernos
internacionales tienen que estar al lado
de la justicia y la libertad para todos
y todas